and minimalists hello everybody welcome
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua Fields Milburn and I'm Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists today we're gonna talk about
bucking the status quo we're gonna talk
about embracing your own idiosyncrasies
we're gonna talk about what happens when
you refuse to conform and to do that
we've got well we've got a special guest
here
Jason's hook is with us today he's an
expert nonconformist I try he's also the
author of a new book on your weird
I figure we would hear if you're
watching this on YouTube here is here is
the cover of the book there's a pig with
a bunch of balloons on the front now
we'll get to your name in a moment we're
actually gonna talk about a bunch of
stuff today Jason about you but I'm
gonna start with a confession okay I
haven't read this book yet and I so I'm
gonna start with a confession and an
apology
I lost the copy you sent me and I when's
the last time I ever lost anything Ryan
I know that's usually my move never I
don't I don't think I've ever lost
anything and and so I don't know what
Freud would say about this
maybe I'm conforming and but anyway so
I'm gonna apologize that this is this I
don't think has ever happened to me
where we've had a guest on where I and
I haven't read I haven't read their book
but it's gonna give you a great
opportunity to explain it to me and to
our audience and I think the best way to
start here is so let's just go ahead and
dive into some questions from the
audience and then we'll unpack the book
as well
our first question is from Jessica in
Pittsburgh about three years ago I quit
a potentially very lucrative very secure
job that I had made a very long time to
get well I hated it and because I wanted
to stay at home and raise my two kids
recently I've also started a very small
woodworking business woodworking is
something I've always loved doing and I
followed some of your advice and went
for it I'm actually listening to your
podcast in my shop which I found kind of
ironic because I'm making things my
business slogan is useful beautiful
yours because everything I make is
custom exactly to what my clients
mostly I built kids playthings train
tables furniture other home decor items
some of the stuff that my clients asked
for are not items that I would
personally build for myself or have in
my own home but my question is how do I
come to terms with creating more stuff
for this world even though it is my
passion to build things when I myself
tried to get rid of my own possessions
and keep my home as simple as I can
Jessica you're you're really part of the
problem here we don't want you to make
things we're just gonna like shame
Jessica and then move on we're really
again in fact that we brought Jason on
here so we could shame him for writing a
physical book I mean here's the I think
we get a bit confused about this because
we will conflate like overindulgent
consumerism with the the craft of of
creating meaningful things and it seems
to me like like jessica is actually
creating something that people are
getting value from yeah I would say
congratulations for like leaving your
job that you hated that was sucking your
soul and like you are actually doing
something now that's meaningful and and
Jessica like that's awesome like I would
never discourage anyone from doing
something that they feel is meaningful
and you know something she said too
about how she makes these pieces of
furniture that she wouldn't have herself
like that's that's okay there are
certain things that people do that feel
is meaningful that I would look at and
not think are meaningful but my opinion
doesn't really matter what matters is
who's who's deliberately getting
Jessica's furniture the creations that
that she is making like it's minimalism
is about being deliberate and it sounds
like there's a lot of deliberate
thoughts and things going into this I
like the part about the fact that she
quit the job that she hated she's making
maybe not the most meaningful work right
now but she's out of the thing that was
terrible for her so it's phases right
like she's not you're not gonna go from
terrible situation to perfect life just
like you're not gonna go from house full
of things to house with absolutely
nothing overnight and and I only know
this because I've lived the same thing
for myself like when you have a job you
hate it's a career dungeon like that's
kind of what it is it's not just a
nine-to-five you're trapped in it's
something you can't get out of and so I
think you know for someone in this
I think we've all been there it's phases
so you don't have to see it as this is
your forever it's just this is the now
and I want to put food on the table I
want to pay the bills I want to make
things whether you feel like they're
super meaningful or not you're gonna
kind of get to that place only by going
through these different phases yeah yeah
that's a great point I think maybe she
needs to redefine what is is meaningful
as well because it does seem to me that
what she's doing is adding value to
other people's lives and if that's what
you're doing you're serving the greater
good and and I think what we need to do
is figure out that that if if you are
serving the greater good if someone is
well if you're creating something for
someone else then I don't I think maybe
you're struggling with something you
shouldn't be struggling with because
you're identifying well if I make
anything then it is actually part of the
problem when that's not it at all no
like I look at I look at any creator and
you know I look at like what is it that
they're putting into the world now
Jessica was like you know I got into the
fast fashion industry and I got to come
up with a new line of clothing every
single week and I know it's wasteful and
it's hurtful to the environment I mean
there are obviously some values there
that she is going against but it doesn't
sound like she's going against any of
her values I mean we don't when Josh and
I speak about minimalism or simplicity
or what I mean we're the minimalist
because the domain was available for
seven bucks I mean I try not to get too
hung up on that word because it can have
such a you know just a stark connotation
sometimes but but when we we talk about
consumption it's not that consumptions a
problem like I'm drinking coffee
I read Jason's book I did read Jason's
well you're welcome
I I use a laptop I use a cell phone now
I would much rather have like a
biodegradable laptop or a biodegradable
cell phone right so when I think about
what people are good also I mean there
are some things that we do that
sometimes we turn a blind eye to it and
I don't have a good answer to that I
mean my phone is made essentially by
intention servants yeah yeah I don't I
don't know how to deal with that
cognitive dissonance that we we all have
it right who's there there are other
things like the making of
the woodwork which you don't need to
have cognitive dissonance over that this
does it that this probably aligns with
your values yeah especially if your
values include creativity yeah so if
you're creating something the you know
it's it's not about like I shouldn't be
creating anything and I feel bad for
putting more things into this world I
mean the question is is like what are
you creating why are you creating it are
you are you in alignment with your
values like that is those are gonna be
much more powerful questions and how can
I stop creating something altogether
yeah Jason you're you're quite the
creator not of woodworking things though
unfortunately yet I can imagine there's
something in your future here but let's
talk a little bit about in your book
which I haven't read I do think it is
kind of funny though because we know
each other so you do have the context of
knowing some of my projects some of the
crazy things you've done
so I think it's a little bit different
than someone that comes in here cold and
you're like all right I haven't read
your book who the hell are you you know
we have conversations we've known each
other since 2013 like it's been a while
so I think that is a slight difference
so maybe that was why you lost lost it
that I sent you and Ryan didn't you know
like I don't know when I was going
through it it was it was just a little
bit more in-depth of the stories I
already knew about you so yeah I totally
see what you're saying I mean yes for
all intensive purposes Josh you have
read most of the book because you know
Jason well let's talk about the
weirdness thing here because jessica has
done something that is non-conforming it
is weird in a way and she's actually
struggling with owning it right now yes
yeah so this is what this is the entire
ethos of the book is the fact that
you're weird
just like minimalism is how you define
it so it's not about how you guys live
your lives it's minimalist it's not
about how I live my life as a mineral is
because I do identify as that but I am
also way weirder than people like you
than people like Jessica and people like
anybody else and I own that and I'm okay
with that and I think that again it goes
back to what I said about the phases it
doesn't happen all at once you don't
just go okay I'm a woodworker who makes
unicorn furniture and that's all that I
do and then people go okay that's who
you are you have to get to that phase
and I'm not saying that she's going to
do that all the great idea if you want
to do that I'll buy a piece I just think
that that's a really interesting part of
this is to figure out
who you are understand what makes you
different because that is the thing that
we all buy into whether you listen to
this podcast or another one or I'm
friends with you guys it's because of
who you are not because of just what you
stand for because that really is the
texture that aligns us it's what makes
us interesting it's what makes us fun
and I think that for me and all the
weird stuff that I've done I've just
found that the more weird that I am it
makes me feel more me and so I think for
everybody to figure out what that
definition is for them is just what I'm
trying to do in the book that you're
gonna be different from other people
you're gonna stand out from the crowd
you're not gonna have the nine-to-five
job you're not gonna be a normal
woodworker maybe and that's okay
and you just own it and you you get to
that point where it starts to feel more
comfortable the more that you do yeah
all right well Jessica I'm gonna send
you a copy of two books one is owned
you're weird by Jason hook we're Justin
you copy that also I'd love to send you
a copy of minimalism live a meaningful
life it's Ryan's in my first book and
since we're talking about conformity
today this was this was apropos the
first line of this book if I am
remembering it correctly is conformity
is the drug with which many people
self-medicate nice and and I think
that's when we're talking about not
conforming and we're actually gonna talk
about maybe some of the benefits of
conforming as well today I think I think
there's much to recommend with
conformity in some instances so we can
talk about that but I think you'll find
value in minimalism little meaningful
life because it actually helps you
identify what your values are and then
live congruent with those values
realizing you're gonna be different what
makes your life exciting is you have
relationships with people who have
different values I'm sorry who have
different beliefs have different
interests different idiosyncrasies
different personalities but the the
alignment of values is often very
similar so if you like our podcast you
like the audiobook version of minimalism
live a meaningful life Shawn if you
could reach out to Jessica send that to
or if she wants the book book or the
e-book we're happy to send those to you
as well as well as a copy of own you're
weird
Ryan what time is it you know what time
it is it is time for our lightning round
where we answer questions from social
media indeed we do we are at the
minimalists on Twitter Facebook and
Instagram Jason I believe you're at
Jason does stuff and so you can follow
him there now we try to just I guess we
create
think pithy here we answer questions
with the short shareable less than
hundred forty character response which
Shawn tweezers out puts them in the show
notes we call the minimal Maxim's
Jessica collects them all at minimal
Maxim's calm but really we just ramble
on a bit until we find something pithy
we pass here we've had time to like
prepare our answers you haven't so you
can just ramble and then Sean will clean
it up and post and make it nice and
pretty
what's our first question alright first
question is from Natalie how do I
address the disappointment of my family
and friends when I choose different
paths in life than the ones they believe
are most ideal for me Jason do you talk
about this in your book at all yeah it's
one thing that I've in fact we were
collecting questions for this the same
question kept coming up over and over it
was effectively this question it
manifests differently works like my
computer my community doesn't accept me
my parents don't accept me my spouse
doesn't accept me people don't accept me
if I don't make decisions based on
everyone around me I mean the problem
with that is if you're trying to appease
everyone you're going to appease no one
oh that's pithy sean my pithy answer is
you won't get to your destination you
won't get to your destination by taking
their path especially if you have 15
different people with 15 different paths
in their life and I feel like you just
sort of you're going down everyone
else's path you're not gonna discover
your own yeah and I really feel like
it's about what you need to get out of
the relationships that you have and so
the ones with your family are about love
and connection and all of that stuff but
the ones maybe for your work life or for
really who you are deep down as a person
you may need to leave that close
community for those things that's what
my wife and I did we left Florida to
come to California because we felt
completely out of alignment with the
life we had in Florida our family is all
still there and we still go back and
visit them and we love them we talked to
them but sometimes you have to get out
of your comfort zones to actually find
the right fit for you in life yeah also
running towards something you you as
opposed to running away from
Jacksonville Oh which is a good memoir
title I you you found the place to run
toward and a community to run toward it
and I think that's a port because it
actually accomplishes two things it does
help you remove yourself from
the previous situation to some extent
like you said you still have family
there you still maintain these loose
ties you may not see them face to face
every day but you're still able to
maintain a meaningful relationship with
them from a distance Natalie the only
person you need and disappoint is
yourself and that is the truth like
you've got to be able to look in the
mirror and feel good about what you're
doing if you're doing everything that
your parents are telling you to do well
then you're not being you
you're being them or you're being a
version of what they want you to be but
you've you've got to be yourself and you
got to find a way to do that I will say
it like it's so difficult because we
want approval I want Josh's approval I
want Jordans approval
I want Suk's approval I want Podcast
Sean's approval like I you know approval
is something that I want but I'm not
going to forsake approval over my own
self-worth yeah if you get everyone's
approval but are living incongruent with
the person you want to be you're still
gonna be you're gonna be the most
approved miserable person in the world
yeah and and and it's you see it in
politics especially right and where
people they try to appeal to everyone
and so they use the sort of double-talk
and this nuance speak and it's it's very
strange because when you see the the
most vanilla candidate that sort of
tries to appeal to everyone they end up
appealing to no one yeah no it's
absolutely true and Jessica like you're
I'm sorry Natalie you got to think like
your family you hit the nail on the head
Jason like your family is is there to
love and support you you are there to
love and support them and if they're
gonna base their love and support off of
what you do for a profession or what
school you go to I mean I would push
back on them and ask them if that's
really showing you love yeah and I
really think that you see this in
business too like when you sell things
that don't align with your core values
at the end of the day that money doesn't
feel rich it doesn't feel like it's
bringing you any actual joy and you that
to me is like the version of selling out
is when you're doing those things and
they're not actually aligning with what
you want to do and and I think the
family stuff does get tough I mean
listen I'm a black sheep in my family
because I'm the only entrepreneur I'm
the only person who's gone out
and publicly failed a bit and had a
bunch of stuff that I put out into the
world but it's also what has made me
feel the most me and so I think that
that's important for someone like
Natalie for anybody like us who we just
enjoy sharing our stories and that our
families may not see those eye-to-eye
but that's okay it's not for them to see
everything we do I die if it really is
what lights us up and makes us feel
great how do they up to you over time
though I mean because I'm sure first
when you're out there you're failing
publicly or succeeding publicly even it
is different from their idea of success
how did they end up warming up to you or
did they well yeah I think it just it
comes from repetitive time for me of
like all these weird ideas that I kept
doing they finally just maybe realize
like okay
this is who he is it's not a one and
then he's gonna come back and be like
this kid that we knew growing up it's oh
this is who he is he's going to keep
doing this so we need to accept him for
this and that to me it just kind of came
naturally with my family thankfully I
didn't have too much trouble with that
but I do know people who've had a lot of
trouble with that and I think the thing
that I would say to them and have said
to people in those positions is just
keep telling your family that you love
them no matter what it is that you do
you still love them and you hope that
they love you back and that's all you
can do yeah absolutely I you know what
did you said something about how you
know over time you just kept doing this
you know the you were consistent
basically as a way that I took that and
I think that's what's key men like what
your family wants to see is they want to
see consistency consistently yourself
yeah they want to see you consistently
yourself and they also want they also
want to see some level of certainty or
some level of like you being able to
live a meaningful life and as long it
right yeah that's the thing like not
just going I'm gonna try this thing and
then you kind of float to all these
different directions like no I'm gonna
do this thing this is Who I am
I'm owning my weird and I'm really gonna
own it I'm gonna show up consistently
and I'm gonna be myself and authenticity
is the thing that gets passed around a
ton but if you really own it and you
really are that person I think your
family and your friends and people will
come around and if they don't that's
okay then those people just kind of
phase out of your life and that's
alright too
yeah I mean well my family first you
know when my mom first found the
minimalists calm by googling my name I
mean she was she was just not very
supportive and a lot of my family wasn't
a lot of my close friends were I don't
say weren't supportive but they
they weren't like yeah yeah that is true
but what happens is after being
consistent after seeing like oh this is
authentically Ryan that is when you
start when I started to gain that
support from from friends and family you
have someone's been mocking or then that
is also that's a nice red flag of all I
should probably distance myself from
them because they're so insecure that
you we often say judgment is but a
mirror that reflects the insecurities of
the person who's doing the judging and
I'm gonna pause real quick because
Jordan or Sean or someone the sound
panel is crooked and my OCD is flaring
you can keep recording this because
we're gonna keep going as Jordan fixes
our next questions from Kate right our
next question is from Kate Kate wants to
know is maintaining traditions with
family and friends particularly during
the holidays a healthy practice or
should we always be striving to
challenge the status quo you know this
is this is a fascinating question
because and I think we're gonna talk a
little bit later about reinventing the
wheel constantly so I won't use that
metaphor right now but here's my pit the
answer if you don't like your current
traditions create new ones because
here's the thing I think traditions
exist for a reason people have found
them to be useful in the past doesn't
mean they'll necessarily be useful in
the future but if there are hundreds or
thousands of years of tradition whether
it is religion or it is ritual there are
useful things within that there are also
other things that are probably not
useful that you can do away with but in
fact I was listening to who was it
Jonathan Hite who was talking about the
the rain dance is more is more useful
than not having a rain dance but even if
you're part of a tribe that has a rain
dance because know the rain dance
probably doesn't make it rain let's all
acknowledge that
and but it actually brings the community
together in a way that if they had no
similar ritual that you wouldn't have
that same connectedness or that
closeness and so there are traditions
that are actually really useful where
they become harmful as if they get in
the way of the greater good you were
talking about the environment earlier or
things like that there are some
traditions that are harmful that are
exclusionary that hurt people those
traditions are bad but a lot of
traditions are actually good and if you
don't have a good tradition you can you
can obviously create a new one
absolutely so what do you think about
like just bucking the status quo for the
sake of bucking the status quo or
challenging the status quo Jason yeah I
mean this has been my mantra and even
through the past couple years but then
in writing this book I just kind of kept
thinking the way things have been done
is not the way things we're the way
things have always been done is not the
way things have to be done so whether
it's traditions whether it's you know
family things whether it's the way that
you work to me I just feel like we don't
have to stay in these same cycles and I
think it's just happening faster now and
so 30 years ago if you wanted to start a
different business than anyone had
started it's really difficult because
you can only see what you could see but
it goes all the way back to Henry Ford
right like what do people want if you
ask them they want a faster horse they
don't know what a car is right so you
have to figure out what that thing is
for you
whether its traditions and then you make
that new tradition that's very different
or whether like for me it's just coming
up with all these weird ideas and just
going oh things don't have to be done
the same way they've always been done I
can do that something this way I can try
something this way but it's like you
said before I have to stay consistent to
it and I have to stay true to it so I
can't just put it out there and go oh it
didn't work after a month now I have to
give up it's the same thing we're trying
to become a minimalist like oh I went
into my closet and I tried to give away
some things but man those college jeans
like couldn't give them away and then
you give up right for or you give it all
away but then you don't know why you're
doing and so a month later all of a
sudden you've got all these new things
in your closet actly yeah yeah
my pet the answer is this bucking the
status quo for the sake of bucking is
not meaningful so when when I think
about bucking the status quo when I've
done it in my life when I've really
challenges that it's status quo and
have bifurcated from the status quo it
is to grow it's to learn it is to live a
more meaningful life but you know I
think you could kind of say the same
thing about tradition like following
tradition for the sake of tradition also
isn't meaningful right so so legend that
tradition we just did a podcast episode
with Irwin McManus who is a pastor of a
large church across the street and and
the the the whole topic there was about
questioning beliefs questioning faith
and and questioning religion questioning
atheism but you you make your belief
stronger if you're willing to question
them yeah absolutely and I think some
traditions are great I mean going back
to that word consistency I mean we all
need some consistency in our life I mean
even me who is a DD and all over the
place there are still some things like I
need to be consistent within some
traditions can bring that consistency
and oh by the way they can add value to
you your friends your family so yeah
bucking the status quo for the sake of
it not very meaningful but yeah
certainly Kate you know if you're if you
are in some traditions right now that
you want to question it's okay to
question them but but don't just go
against them for the sake of being a
rebel and I would also say one thing
that I've just learned in my life is
there's a difference between questioning
something and there's another
questioning and presenting another idea
yeah so it's so much easier to get
someone's buy-in if you're not just
going why are we doing this but it's
going why are we doing this can we try
this and so like my wife and I created a
new Christmas tradition where we don't
buy each other gifts but we pick a movie
we pick a snack and we pick an activity
and we both do that for each other and
it's so fun it's so dim but we've never
seen anybody do it but we just kept
sitting through Christmases every year
going why are we doing the same thing
over and over let's make something up
and and that becomes a really
interesting thing when you start to
think oh let me not just go up against
the system let me present a new idea to
make it a little bit easier or softer
for someone to go sure let's try that
like that does sound like a good idea
maybe a little uncomfortable because
change is very uncomfortable but let's
try something new and here's an
opportunity to get better or just have
fun or break a tradition that's been
around forever
yeah like shooting down an idea without
having something else that present isn't
gonna get you very far for sure and
what's nice about that is that idea is
also adjacent to the current idea it's
not like well you know we're gonna
not have instead of Christmas today
we're going to go out and you know I
don't know go trick-or-treating kill
Puffy's alright Jace it looks like we
got a we got a bunch more surprise
questions this week including sometimes
I feel isolated or weird for not
following the status quo could you offer
some suggestions for overcoming those
hard feelings also how do you find a new
community when your current community no
longer works for you is there some value
in confronting or maintaining the status
quo we're also going to talk to Jason
about all the weird things he's done
over the last decade well at least some
of the weird things including several
years when he was paid to wear a bunch
of different t-shirts yeah
which sounds like B also I'm wearing a
t-shirt shouldn't I get paid for that
and then why you also sort of got burnt
out on that we're gonna talk about the
time that he sold his last name twice
two different years and so Zook is not
his original last name neither is
headsets.com
and oh he wrote a fully sponsored book
and we don't do any sponsorships on our
podcast or any advertisement so we're
gonna talk about that maybe we will
agree maybe we'll disagree but you wrote
an entire book that was just full of
advertisements for lack of a better term
and and we're gonna talk about the time
that Jason sold his future and much more
and if you want to hear all that you can
listen to this week's maximal episode
available exclusively on patreon that's
right you're currently listening to our
weekly minimal episode but each week
Ryan and I record an entirely different
much longer maximal episode on the
minimalist private podcast which gives
us the private space we need to talk
about topics we don't usually discuss in
public plus patreon is the best way for
us to fund this podcast and keep it 100%
advertisement free when you subscribe to
the minimalist private podcast on
patreon you'll also receive a personal
link so that our maximal episodes play
in your favorite podcast app find all
the details and all the good stuff over
at the minimalists dot-com slash support
also let me say this we are capping our
patreon audience has 6,000
patrons and we're more than two-thirds
of the way there at this point are
really close to two-thirds of the way
there actually and so get in now while
you can if you want to be part of that
audience I know it's just a couple bucks
but that a couple dollars goes a long
way for us since we don't do
advertisements on this podcast Ryan what
else you got for us being informed is
more important than ever so I want to
encourage people to read more and get
informed if you're getting all of your
you know reading material from Facebook
headlines or media headlines I would
encourage you to get out there and read
some other things all right I also have
some voicemail comments and tips from
our listeners checkmate hi my name is
Helen I'm from Vista California just
heard your podcast number 38 on my walk
and you were mentioning travel I wanted
to point out that there's another
organization but besides couchsurfing
I'd love we'd like to get to check out
it's called service ser das and you can
find them online there's a u.s.
organization and a global organization
and they've been providing the host
traveller mute at service for years it's
a little bit more structure than
couchsurfing so it tends to be it might
be more familiar more comfortable for
people that like to like a little bit
more embedding when they're traveling
and visiting with people but we've been
hosts for over ten years and we've had
some visitors from some amazing
organizations
hi this is Paula Noble and I live in
Kearney Missouri calling because I just
listened to your podcast on criticism
which was really good and it made me
think of this quote by Teddy Roosevelt
that Bernie Brown he probably heard of
likes to talk about about criticism and
called them in in the arena and you've
probably heard it but just if you have
I'll go ahead and read it to you but it
goes it is not the critic who counts not
the man who points out how the strong
man stumbles or where the doer of Deeds
could have done them better the credit
belongs to the man who was actually in
the arena whose face is marred by dust
and sweat and blood who strives
valiantly who airs who comes short again
and again because there is no effort
without error and shortcoming but who
does actually strive to do the deeds who
knows great enthusiasms the great
devotions who spends himself in a worthy
cause but the best knows in the end the
triumph of high achievement and who at
the worst if he fails at least fails
while daring greatly so that his place
shall never be with those cold and timid
souls who neither know victory nor
defeat
alright y'all thanks again to Jason Zook
for joining us today
check out his book on your weird
wherever you get books we'll also put a
link to that in the show notes he also
has a podcast called wandering aim for
it's also the name of his website he and
his wife run together it's like a a nice
tight-knit community speaking of
tight-knit communities let's move on to
right here right now here's one thing
that's going on in the life of the
minimalist I was gonna talk about
minimalism that life our side project
you can check that out of course but
since we talked about community quite a
bit especially on the patreon maximal
episode we talked about getting in with
different communities finding new
communities one way to do that we've
mentioned is like meetup calm or places
like that Facebook groups but we also
have something called minimalist org
which we don't always talk about a lot
on the podcast some of that has grown
organically Ryan and I in 2014 we went
to a hundred different cities and had
119 different events and we left behind
meetup groups in all of those cities and
many of them are still going many of
them are flourishing right now if you
want to connect with open minded or
like-minded people locally or in a city
near you it's eight different countries
right
eight countries hundred cities and also
oh there's the online city to if so if
there isn't a city close to you you can
connect with the the online city as well
just head on over to minimalist dot org
we'll put a link to that in the show
notes as well if you have a question
comment or minimalism tip for our
podcast please live with a voicemail for
zero six two one nine seven eight three
nine especially the tips minimalism tips
you have a much better chance of getting
aired also of course write them down
before you call in because that will
make you sound extremely articulate to
the rest of our audience we're always
looking for minimalism tips that we can
borrow and re appropriate as our own
tips later on know we give you full
credit of course you can send a voice
memo to podcast at the minimalists comm
as well you can comment on this episode
at youtube.com slash the minimalist if
you want our show notes in your inbox
sign up for our email list at the
minimalists comm you'll also receive our
simple Sunday emails for our added value
this week let's listen to a song from
noah Gunderson's new album lover now
this just came out last friday ryan and
it was so unfortunate did you see the
taylor swift's album also came out the
same day oh and her album is also called
lover no way yeah i think it was a
surprise album too so he's had this plan
for months and i'm she may not know
anything about it but but you know what
the word i mean if it's good work it'll
stand alone yeah and it really does and
you know here's the thing I say about
noah Gunnarsson's albums i think they're
all remarkable that this might be my
favorite of his it might be his best
album and is different from his previous
albums it has evolved in a way where
it's it's not rock music it's not pop
music it's not singer-songwriter it's
sort of an amalgamation of all three
it's really beautiful it's heartfelt
it's full of sort of rumination it's a
highly personal album you can tell that
he's he's considering a lot of things
there's some despair in there but
there's also some hope and there are so
many good songs on this album but I
think my favorite might be the fourth
track on the album it's called
watermelon so what's in this episode
with that track here is watermelon from
Noah Gunderson's new album love
and if you leave here today with just
one message we hope it's this love
people and use things because the
opposite never works thanks for listen
y'all we'll see you next time and
minimus